it's a sunny Winter's day in angiora and
Benji's enjoying himself at the reserve
waiting for his best pal rocker to turn
up
and here comes Rocco now and what's he
wearing well call me a poodle is that
that new waimakarini District Council
registration tag it's not just any old
registration tag it's the new durable
aluminum multi-year tag you mean no more
plastic tags that bamboozle our owners
every year that's right one tag that
lasts ages as long as you're not too
rough they'll save our humans some
dollars and maybe they'll get us
more treats exactly and it's got this
fancy call for when they leave the door
open
did I tell you about that time I got to
ride in the truck with my Council
friends
it's just lucky you're registered so you
can find your way home again you'll be
barking mad not to be it helps to keep
us all safe like when we go on solo
walkies or when the shepherd next door
is barking the house down
[Music]
well don't get caught sniffing make sure
you get registered on the posting the
postie rare the council send your new
eco-friendly tag with the posting find
out more at
waimakariri.govt.nz forward slash dogs